im stoff strategie beschlossen
trotz des aktuellen impfstoff
überschusses für deutschland weiteren
impfstoff bestellen das folgt der logik
der logik auch der letzten legislatur
gesetzen auf ein breites portfolio von
impfstoffen wir müssen auf alle
eventualitäten vorbereitet sein die
pandemie ist noch nicht vorbei wir
werden diese impfstoffe benötigen wir
wissen aber nicht welche varianten im
herbst und konfrontieren werden es gibt
ja zwei serotypen den serotyp 1 die
sogenannten hahn varianten den so 2g
omikron varianten zur johann variante
gehört auch die data variante wir wissen
das ist dieser varianten auch dort noch
gibt wo die omikron feiern sich weit
verbreitet haben aber wir können nicht
vorhersagen
mit welchen varianten wir im herbst
ringen müssen daher sind wir gut
vorbereitet bereits für die u bahn
varianten dort haben wir ausreichend
impfstoff beschafft dieser impfstoff ist
geschafft worden auf der grundlage der
verträge der letzten legislaturperiode
wir werden auch einen angepassten
omikron reinen omikron impfstoff
bekommen von der firma bei und packte es
ebenfalls bereits also den bestellt und
beschafft wurden auf der grundlage
bestehender verträge was noch fehlt ist
ein sogenannter bivalenten impfstoff an
impfstoff der für die wohin variante wie
für die online variante wirkt über
diesen also impfstoff haben wir uns
heute
verständigt da wird von der firma
moderner vorbereitet und wir werden also
somit im haushalt war 3 830 millionen
euro bereitstellen um auch diesen
impfstoff beschaffen zu können dann
hätten wir im herbst ein impfstoff
und einen omikron eben stoff und viva
lenton impfstoff von der firma moderne
eine lehre aus der pandemie ist nie
wollen wir wieder zu wenig impfstoff
haben wir bereiten daher auch eine
impfkampagne vor um den impfstoff
verhelfen zu können wenn er
im herbst spätestens gebraucht wird
möchten all denjenigen die das brauchen
oder wünschen eine vierte impfungen
anbieten können auch dann mit den
adaptierten impfstoffen wir können nicht
über nacht impfen wir wollen aber so
schnell wie möglich impfen können und
aus dem grunde werden auch die
impfzentren weitergeführt und werden vom
bund mit maximal 100 millionen euro pro
monat unterstützt werden ich wünsche mir
auch ein zweites thema ansprechen
schaute schon ausgeführt die pandemie
ist nicht vorbei darüber hinaus müssen
wir uns aber auch damit beschäftigen
dass es neue pandemien geben kann und
das wird gegenstand auch unsere
beratungen mit den g7 ländern sein meine
kollegen und ich werbe dafür dass wir
einen pandemie pakt schließen dieser
pandemie packt zukünftige ausbrüche
schneller erkennen und effektiver darauf
reagieren können ich habe daher also
zusammen mit der whu und mit aus
internationalen experten im rahmen der
vorbereitung für dieses g7-treffen
ein vorschlag entwickelt wie also
schneller auf zukünftige pandemien
reagiert werden kann da spielt die
überwachung von ausbrüchen eine rolle
ein schnelles eingreifen wenn es eine
ausbruch situation gibt so dass eine
pandemie verhindert werden kann schnelle
entwicklung von wirkstoffen zur
behandlung der erkrankung aber auch
schnelle entwicklung von impfstoffen
gesetzen also in diesem pakt von
pandemic readynas darauf dass ein
weltumspannendes system geschaffen
werden kann womit pandemien verhindert
werden können indem ausbrüche schneller
bekämpft werden können mit allen zur
verfügung stehenden mitteln und darüber
werden wir wahrscheinlich am freitag
einen wegweisenden beschluss treffen
können es kann allerdings auch nicht
überblickt also kann aber auch nicht
über darf nicht übersehen werden dass
die mit dem klimawandel
einhergehenden steigenden temperaturen
zukünftige pandemie geschehnisse
wahrscheinlich für machen studien die es
gibt
machen uns besorgt in bezug auf die
exponentiell zu nehmende gefahr von
pandemien wenn es zu einem linearen
anstieg der temperaturen kommt und das
muss hier also beachtet werden daher
werden wir auch im bereich von
klimawandel und gesundheit uns intensiv
damit beschäftigen in welcher art und
weise der klimawandel zum einen
pandemien aber zum sollten auch
erkrankungen die mit dem klimawandel an
hergehen und der zunehmenden temperatur
also verstärkt auftreten werden
schließlich werden wir uns im rahmen der
g7 besprechungen mit dem thema
antibiotikaresistenz und
auseinandersetzen weltweit versterben
bereits jetzt 1,3 millionen menschen pro
jahr an antibiotika resistenzen mit
steigender tendenz wir haben an der
situation hervor uns die langfristig
darauf hinauslaufen könnte dass wir
klassische infektionskrankheiten nicht
mehr ausreichend mit antibiotika
behandeln können weil die resistenzen
dies also unmöglich machen auch damit
müssen wir also ringen und daher werden
wir am donnerstag und am freitag uns mit
diesen drei problemen beschäftigen kann
der micra dig-s auf der einen seite
daneben klimawandel und gesundheit und
verhinderung von
antibiotikaresistenz nicht die letzte
sein wir werden diese pakte beschließen
wir wollen das zusammen mit der wir es
schaffen und daher also wollen wir eine
starke wm eine globale stärker
abgestimmte planung überwachung und auch
eine besser ausfinanzierte wie hier wird
ein ziel sein
wir kommen zurück zu ihren frank for
android
angesprochen haben vor allem was die
beiden neuen angepassten impfstoffe von
moderner und bei und hier kann geht
haben sie da jeweils so viele dosen
geschafft dass die gesamte bevölkerung
zumindest die über fünfjährige
bevölkerung damit geimpft werden kann
und sie sagten jeder der es wünscht
könne eine vierte impfung bekommen
rechnen sie damit dass eine empfehlung
gibt für jeden sich viert zu impfen
von dem was wir
geschafft haben können wir sagen dass
also für alle drei impfstoffe wo hahn im
stoff omikron eben stoff bivalenten
impfstoff vor uns von der
impfbereitschaft die wir antizipieren
jeder der also hier sich impfen lassen
möchte und von dem wir es also
voraussetzen sich mit einem dieser
impfstoffe hinterlassen könnte und zur
zweiten frage natürlich wäre hier eine
empfehlung der stiko wünschenswert wenn
es dafür die medizinischen grundlagen
gibt die medizinischen grundlagen kann
aber derzeit nicht abgeschätzt werden
weil wir ja nicht wissen welche variante
kommt wenn es also zum beispiel so wäre
das also eine variante kommt die ein
starkes es geht phänomen aus der flucht
phänomen hat gegen die braves
bestehenden impfstoffe aber schwer
verläuft dann könnte man sich sehr gut
vorstellen dass es dann eine empfehlung
gibt für die angepassten impfstoffe für
alle wenn es aber so kommt dass die
unterschiede in bezug auf die
wirksamkeit der angepassten impfstoffe
und der vorhandenen impfstoffe gering
ist und die bevölkerung noch gut
geschützt ist dann würde man eine solche
empfehlung der stiko nicht unbedingt
erwarten können daher kann man das jetzt
noch nicht pauschal beantworten sondern
es hängt davon ab wie tatsächlich das
infektionsgeschehen sich verändert und
welche variante uns dann begegnet er
inkl
zwei fragen einmal zu den zur rät
gesundheitsorganisation sie haben die
finanzen erwähnt ist denn ihrer meinung
nach jetzt die neuordnung der finanzen
und eine dauerhafte sichere finanzierung
gewährleistet oder wo sehen sie noch
probleme und dann haben sie auf die
abwendung neuer termin hingewiesen aber
ist nicht ein kriterium dabei das
vertrauen und was auch ein problem bei
der beim ausbruch der kogit panini
fürchten sie nicht dass mögliche
versuche das künftig besser zu machen
durch diese frontstellung die wert auf
der welt haben möglicherweise
unterlaufen werden kann ist die letzte
frage nur wiederholen ich konnte die
frage akustisch nicht verstehen
frage noch mal wieder wo ich konnte die
letzte frage akustisch nicht richtig
also bei der letzten frage ging es darum
ob man eine pandemie die waren eine
pandemie verhindert und ob dafür nicht
vertrauen notwendig ist dadurch dass wir
im moment aber in der welt auf der einen
seite china russland als beispiele
genannt auf der anderen seite die
westliche welt so eine polarisierung
sehen haben sie sorge dass pandemien
möglicherweise schlechter bekämpft
werden können weil die länder sich nicht
mehr vertrauen bei der weitergabe von
daten vielen dank die
finanzielle situation der whu ist nicht
optimal aber konnte deutlich verbessert
werden somit also betone ich hier das
positive und wir haben uns aus
deutschland auch dann stark beteiligt
und daher als die whu aus meiner sicht
also
besser finanziert als in der
vergangenheit aber der weg muss
fortgeschritten werden ich weise darauf
hin dass wir auch also darauf abzielen
was der also
intelligence hat der whu hier in berlin
also von deutschland stark mit also
gefördert wird und das ist eine
deutliche verbesserung der wohnsituation
für also pandemien ganz grundsätzlich
und naja deutschland aus meiner sicht an
wichtigen anteil an der finanziellen
ausstattung der wehren auch der
fortführung es ist richtig dass die
pandemie bekämpfung leidet wenn also wir
in eine polarisierte welt kommen
gegenseitiges misstrauen ist daher ist
aber auch aus dem projekt in dem
päckchen denic readynas den wir hier
also besprechen werden eine komponente
enthalten das international
kooperierende gut ausgebildete
spezialisten ein netzwerk bilden welche
sich gegenseitig informiert
vertrauensvoll zusammenarbeitet und auch
über seine politische gräben hinweg in
der pandemie kontrolle also eine
transparenz über das geschehen herstellt
die so die voraussetzung dafür ist dass
pany kontrolle funktionieren kann also
ein umspannendes system von
wissenschaftlern die einander kennen und
vertrauen ist ein wesentlicher baustein
in bezug auf eine bessere vorbeugung von
bannemin
minister sie hatten gesagt mit blick auf
die impfstoff beschaffung man müsse
immer vorbereitet sein das sei die lehre
aus der pandemie gleichzeitig haben wir
aber soweit ich das weiß von den zahlen
die vorliegen sehr viel impfstoff der
noch liegt und möglicherweise verfällt
wie lösen sie diesen widerspruch auf das
eine frage und eine zweite vielleicht
noch mit blick auf maßnahmen im herbst
wie zuversichtlich sind sie dass die fdp
damit spielt
zunächst ist richtig dass auch im stoff
verfällt möchte aber darauf hinweisen
dass der impfstoff der verfällt
ausschließlich impfstoff ist den wir
nicht geschafft haben in dieser
legislaturperiode sondern der aus
verträgen stammt die vorher geschlossen
waren und diese verträge waren richtig
das möchte ich ausdrücklich sagen so
dass hier nicht der eindruck entsteht
wir würden eine neue strategie verfolgen
sondern diese ich sage mal
portfolio strategie die man vorgänger ja
schon gewählt hat war richtig wild auch
von uns weiter also verfolgt und es
liegt eben in der sache begründet werden
auch neue varianten kommen und neue
impfstoffe dann muss man neuen
impfstoffe schaffen derweil auch ein
teil des alten schlosses verfällt das
ist also in der sache begründet und da
muss man eben offen und klar
kommunizieren wir können nicht also
antäuschen aus wenn man jetzt schon
wüsste dass er noch liegende impfstoff
ausreicht um im herbst also klar zu
kommen sondern wir müssen auf varianten
vorbereitet sein die also dann einen
neuen angepassten impfstoff benötigen
und die zweite frage ist also die ich
glaube dass wir uns mit der fdp auf
notwendige maßnahmen sehr gut
verständigen können und
darüber zu spekulieren wo es einen
dissens geben könnte oder nicht das
macht würde keinen sinn machen wir gehen
fest davon aus dass wir im herbst gut
vorbereitet sein werden
bertrams
genau der kollege ist mir schon fast zu
mit sozusagen einem weiter dreh der
frage zuvorgekommen wie sieht es denn
aus mit einer anpassung des
infektionsschutzgesetzes worauf wir
jetzt auch die landesminister gedrungen
haben was sind da konkret ihre
vorstellungen welche einschränkungen
sollte man dann im fall der fälle zügig
wieder hochfahren hochfahren können ich
habe euch die also den beschluss der
gesundheitsministerkonferenz
begrüßt dass man ein neues
infektionsschutzgesetz benötigt für den
winter ich bitte um verständnis dass ich
diese vorschläge die ich selbst richtig
findet dass ich die zunächst erst mit
unseren
koalitionspartnern und auch im kabinett
besprechen und nicht öffentlich hier
ausbreitet das wäre kein guter stil
so richtig verstanden dass der sich zum
herbst impfen lassen will aus drei
verschiedenen vakzin varianten auswählen
kann
genau das ist so also wenn wir die drei
unterschiedlichen vakzine haben dann
gebe es die möglichkeit also die drei
unterschiedlichen wachsen auch
individuell zu wählen natürlich ist es
so wenn wir dann eine variante haben wo
eine vakzine besonders gut wirkt was
dann die studien zeigen würden dann wird
die mehrheit der bevölkerung diese
vakzine haben wollen und daher war ja
auch die frage von frau emmerich
zielführend und richtig ich muss so viel
impfstoff haben was zur not mit allen
und eben stoff alle geimpft werden
könnten das würde dann natürlich
bedeuten dass sich zwei unterschiedliche
vakzine die nicht wirklich gewählt wurde
nicht verwenden würde aber es ist eben
also der natur der dinge geschuldet dass
ich hier doppelt redundant arbeiten muss
muss nicht darauf verlassen können dass
ich auch dann genug impfstoff habe wenn
nur ein impfstoff von den drei
unterschiedlichen stoffen jetzt
gewünscht würde
da würde ich gerne gleich anschließen
sie haben eben gesagt alle diejenigen
die die bereitschaft haben sich impfen
zu lassen für die gebe es auch in stoff
wenn man ich weiß kann verstehen dass
ich nicht sehr konkret werden wollen
oder können was die genaue
bereitstellung angeht aber etwas von der
bereitschaft rechnen sie auch vor dem
hintergrund dass es sehr wohl keine
große bereitschaft zu einer vierten
impfung gibt ja das hängt eben vom
infektionsgeschehen ab wenn es so wäre
das also schwere verläufe wieder
auftreten würden oder wir hätten einen
impfstoff beim mittleren also verläufen
oder nicht ganz so schwierig verlaufen
der aber die ansteckung vermeidet dann
wäre das interesse sehr groß wenn wir
aber in einer situation kommen dass die
die variante nicht allzu schwer die
menschen befällt und
gleichzeitig die impfstoffe vor der
infektion nicht gut schützen
dann wäre die bereitschaft lich so groß
somit hängen das sehr stark davon ab
also was kommt wenn es jetzt zum
beispiel so wäre das eine schwere
variante kommt und der impfstoff würde
sogar die infektion vermeiden dann wäre
das interesse maximal
so heißt das dann dass sie ist einmal
wenn man wenn sie sagen sie müssen ja
ich sag mal das optimum denken dass sie
weiblich 3 x 50 millionen dosen bestellt
haben sagen also wir haben in der
größenordnung bestellt dass wir also
wenn sich jetzt zum beispiel 40
millionen menschen impfen lassen wollten
wer dies also reicht tun könnten werden
sich aber abzeichnen würde dass ich 40
millionen menschen impfen lassen wollen
können wir die nicht in seiner drei oder
vier wochen nimmt und dann könnten wir
dann wenn das interesse so groß ist was
ich nicht glaube könnten wir dann sogar
noch impfstoff nachbestellen wir kommen
aber nie in einer situation wo wir nicht
all diejenigen impfen könnten die von
einem bestimmten impfstoff gebrauch
machen wollen und sich impfen lassen
wollen
ich sehe keine fragen mehr doch frau
amerika frage noch mal entschuldigen sie
hat noch mal eine nachfrage dazu für den
fall dass wir jetzt über die angepassten
impfstoffe reden im herbst und die
besonders nachgefragt werden sind das
dann einmal dosen oder müsste man zum
beispiel den bivalenten impfstoff von
moderner auch dann wieder in einem
impfschema drei mal impfen damit er
seine wirkung erzeugt ja die impfstoffe
werden derzeit aus allen mal dosen also
antizipiert weil sie in der regel auf
setzen auf eine bad statt gehabt
infektion oder eine impfung mit also
der mit dem buch an impfstoff das ist
auch das was also die daten bisher
zeigen dass das eine einmal nach impfung
beispielsweise mit dem omikron impfstoff
dass das eine sehr gute immunisierung
gibt bei denjenigen die branche aber
gegeben worden sind oder die bereits
erkrankt gewesen sind es war natürlich
eine kleine gruppe geben die bisher sich
haben nie impfen lassen und jetzt
plötzlich bereit sind sich drei mal
impfen zu lassen diese gruppe können wir
mit dem impfstoff den wir geschafft
haben ohne weiteres abdecken weil ich
glaube die gruppe wird nicht so groß
sein
harrington nochmal
es hat ja in der vergangenheit immer
wieder mal diskussionen gegeben ob tim
stoffen national oder europäisch
geschafft werden vielleicht können sie
bitte noch mal sagen wie die künftigen
im stoffe beschafft werden alle
beschaffungen die wir hier gerade
besprochen haben werden europäisch
beschafft und der hat
noch mal vielleicht zum um die leute zu
mobilisieren eine impfkampagne wie
könnte die dann aussehen sehen wenn man
jetzt momentan bereitschaft sieht es ja
nicht so hoch aber wenn sie die wieder
höher bringen wollen wie könnte so eine
impfkampagne die impfkampagne hängt ja
sehr davon ab also erstens welche
varianten müssen dann bekämpft werden
uns um zweiten was ist die
impfempfehlung also haben wir zum
beispiel eine situation wo es eine stiko
empfehlung gibt also dass sich alle noch
einmal impfen lassen sollen für eine
vierte impfung oder haben wir eine
solche empfehlungen nicht auf jeden fall
arbeiten wir an szenarien für
impfkampagnen wollen auf jeden fall also
vier elemente also am platz haben neben
vielen kleineren element liches benennen
könnte wenn wir in den herbst hinein
gehen wir brauchen ein funktionierendes
infektionsschutzgesetz wir brauchen eine
impfstrategie und den dafür notwendigen
impfstoff wir brauchen eine darauf
angepasste impfkampagne und wir müssen
darüber hinaus auch eine situation haben
dass wir also das
krankheitsgeschehen jederzeit
beherrschen können in kommunikation also
vorhaltung von krankenhausversorgung
aber auch von medikamentöser therapie
freundlich
themen schwenk morgen will das
bundesverfassungsgericht seine
entscheidung in sachen einrichtungs
gezogen die impfpflicht verkünden haben
sie dann schon eine erwartungshaltung
wie das gehen wird und falls das falls
karlsruhe nein sagen sollte wie
reagieren sie
also über eine erwartung möchte ich
nicht spekulieren
ich glaube also darf wir dann
entsprechend reagieren können von dem
was wir bisher vorgetragen haben gehe
ich allerdings davon aus dass also die
rechtmäßigkeit der impfpflicht
einrichtungs bezogenen pflicht also
tatsächlich bestätigt wird davon also
gehen hier aus also wir haben sie auch
eingeführt aber
alles andere sind dann brauchen
herzlichen dank für ihren trip